Math is really beautiful, but many students
don't ever get a chance to see it because
we hide that beauty until way too late in
a math student's educational experience.
We're hiding whole amazing areas of mathematics
until the students reach college.
But many of the students don't make it that
far.
They decide before they get there that there's
nothing to see here.
They say they're not a math person because
they're bored with math, because they've been
taught that math is arithmetic.
They haven't been taught that math is discovery.
Math is a creative discipline.
I know a lot of artistically creative people,
the most creative people I know that are mathematicians.
You know, they have to create new frameworks
in which to create new knowledge.They are
creating castles in the sky.
My name is Richard Rusczyk.
I'm the founder of Art of Problem Solving.
We develop educational resources and opportunities
for students who are really interested in
learning.
I did not learn very much in the classroom.
We didn't have the Internet then.
So there was no you know, there was no YouTube
to watch videos.
But I learned a lot from textbooks and working
on problems.
I had a stack of formula sheets and I would
just memorize them and I would eventually
get to a training program for the students
who did well in a series of national competitions.
I'm there for five weeks.
I see 50 or 60 problems during this time,
and I got exactly zero correct.
I had to go back to those formulas and ask,
why is this true?
Why is that true?
And realized that I did not know and had to
start trying to prove some of these things.
I was coming out of a high school that in
northern Alabama, it was an aggressively average
high school.
But I go off to Princeton and I'm worried
about competing against students that went
to magnet school, private schools.
And I found in the first few weeks it was
very clear that I had it backwards.
I had training.
They didn't have.
And that training was all those years staring
at problems I didn't know how to do and having
to learn how to fight through them.
I had learned how to take basic ideas and
solve really difficult problems that could
transfer that general skill into physics,
into computer science, into engineering, into
economics, into philosophy.
We're training kids to compete with computers.
This is what computers do.
They get it right every time.
And when we start training kids to compete
with those computers, we're setting them up
for failure.
And I think this is part of the problem is
this is the way that they are evaluated.
So we need to bring these challenges earlier.
We need to put students in these situations
where they're not going to be able to get
it right the first time or the second time
or the third time.
And the kids know how to handle that.
We trained it out of them.
You look at kids when they're four.
I mean, a four year old kid can't do anything.
But they'll try.
They'll fail.
They'll cry.
They'll run off to their room and then they'll
do something really amazing.
They'll come back really quickly and they'll
try again because they're four and they haven't
learned yet how to quit forever.
Learning's hard.
It is painful.
Yeah, it's a little frustrating, but you're
getting somewhere.
That's.
That's the sign that you are finally getting
somewhere with whatever you're trying to learn
is when you're feeling this kind of discomfort.
If you're comfortable, you're not learning
anything.
I think one of the things that making this
transition to fighting through the problems
as opposed to just knowing how to do it, when
I look at it, is understanding that it's a
process and not an accumulation of knowledge.
It's about being more playful, looking at
the problem and trying to learn about the
situation, remove a few constraints from the
problem and explore or add constraints to
the problem and explore a little bit.
What we don't do is show them how to do it
and then say, okay, this is how we do this
problem.
Here's another one that's similar.
So we show them.
We'll show them a problem.
We'll work through it together.
Like if they get completely stuck, we'll throw
them in some hands or throw them in, kind
of guide them, guide them a little bit, and
then come back and summarize at the end.
Like that last step's pretty important.
Is at the end is to pull out and say, Hey,
look at this general strategy we use.
You can motivate the steps towards that.
And then they'll have another tool in their
tool kit.
I don't think of myself as teaching math.
I think of myself as teaching students problem-solving.
And by problem-solving, I mean teaching students
how to solve problems they've never seen before.
And math is a really powerful way to teach
that.
I think a lot of it is modeling for the student,
the questions we eventually want the student
to learn to ask themselves instead of saying,
Oh, you just add the seven and three.
Here's why.
What we do is walk them through the questions
that one might ask themselves in order to
figure out how to do the thing.
We found that there were a lot of students
out there for whom textbooks were not sufficient.
They needed to interact with each other.
So we started with a community where we could
just bring the kids together online.
And then we started building online learning
systems, adaptive learning system, where you
just give the students problems and lead them
into harder and harder material.
And I started developing videos to go along
with the adaptive learning system.
We have two online schools now.
We have learning centers around the country.
We have 12 learning centers right now.
We have an online community at APS online
that is, oh, hundreds of thousands of learners
from all over the world.
Our textbooks are comic books.
A lot of students are visual learners, and
a lot of mathematical information can be conveyed
really effectively, visually.
We use it for pedagogical reasons as well.
You can't lecture a third grader, but in a
comic book you can simulate conversations.
We can model some of the strategies we want
them to use.
We can model students asking questions.
We can model students working through challenges.
We can model students being wrong and being
okay with that.
All of these resources, they're readily accessible
to those who have the means to pay for them
and those who have parents who know to look
for them.
Meanwhile, we're removing a lot of these opportunities
from schools.
The set of students are getting involved in
these programs is getting narrower and narrower.
So as a result, our country has a much narrower
pool of people who are going into advanced
math and science.
The next step in our evolution is learning
how to work closely with schools where the
delivery mechanism there is the most important
person the student is working within their
educational experience during the day, which
is their teacher.
So we're trying to learn how we are going
to learn how to work with teachers in the
classroom to empower them, to give their students
the experience we give our students.
So we're going to go and find that talent
ourselves by going into the schools so that
we can reach those students who don't have
the means or the knowledge to look for opportunities
outside the classroom.
We need to be drawing talent from across our
entire population.